ziehe die am 1 mein gott
alter bin ich bin ich jetzt irgendwie
[Musik]
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
wieder einer neuen zieht vorstellungen
dies sieht review die ich gestern
hochgeladen habe da war die recht sehr
aktiv und hat mir eine menge sieht es
geschrieben ich habe wieder tolle sitz
gefunden die ich einfach vorstellen
konnte und dies auf einer vorstellung
verdient haben sage ich mal und ich war
heute auch schon circa vier stunden
einfach draußen und hat mit steffen die
bestrafung gedreht für gibt ihm weil er
die erste staffel verloren
wenn ihr nicht wisst was die beam ist da
könnt ihr einfach auf steffens kanal
gehen ich schreibe den euch mal ganz
kurz hier reinigt youtube.com slettvoll
von wolfgang stephan block also nicht
steffens blogs sondern stefan block so
heißt steffens kanada kennt einfach
vorbeischauen auf jeden fall abonnieren
da kommen auch wöchentlich real videos
mit mir und steffen wo wir in
verschiedenen spielen gegeneinander
antreten
das kommt jetzt hier wie seine werbung
einfach rüber weil wollte ich eigentlich
nur sagen kurz er dass wir da halte in
verschiedenen spielen spielen wie zum
beispiel tiefer bei need for speed black
ops hatten wir schon f1 race das kommt
das komme auch real life sachen und so
gabler wieder keine fans kommen nicht
einfach total fertig auch sehr weil ich
total cup oben und gleich duschen möchte
bei fahrten durch braucht bin
der sieht ist harry potter hat mir einen
user unter mein video geschrieben und
letzte sieg zu stellen also wirklich ich
nehme jetzt mal eure sieht auch alle
weil das ist ihr seid echt aktiv drunter
sind schon 700 kommentare oder so ist
echt klasse
natürlich haben wir auch eben ganz
kurzen den shader rhein bis das halb
voll oder fehler weil ich habe die
die dings wohin ganz hof gestellt hatte
das hier habe ich oft ausgestellt das
habe ich sonst mal auf normal nicht weil
mein pc das nicht aushält ihr wisst
glaube ich dass mein pc haushalten würde
aber einfach weil das ganze dann
schließlich zeit
ich finde es schön wenn im hintergrund
so ein bisschen nebel ist das thema
hunger games auch mal voll schön dass
man nicht jetzt komplett weit gucken
kann sondern dass auch im nebel im
hintergrund die welt muss ich jetzt
gerade ein bisschen aufbauen da keinen
plan warum dass man dort
der sieg wird gesendet aber einfach nur
einfach nur hier so ja hier luca problem
an den harry potter einfach aus und ohne
irgendwelche koordinaten also wenn
jemand sendet dann am besten nur noch
mit irgendwelchen koordinaten drin
zum beispiel dann im wie spiderman
koordinaten explorers pyramide und so
ganze scheiß dann können die leute damit
auch besser was anfang allerdings hatte
der kommentar halt irgendwie 30 daumen
hoch oder sondern dachte ich mir dann
haben die 30 leute ausprobiert haben
dann realität dass dieser sieg gut ist
und zwar sind wir da vorne da irgendwo
unter wasser des porta haben jetzt ein
riesiges junge wir da sehen wir hinten
den den nebel ich bin dass ich irgendwie
cool aus mit diesen nebel im hintergrund
und hier haben wir eine menge menge
schweine und wir die waren von auch
schon wochen vorher noch mehr also für
essen ist gesorgt und wir haben ja auch
direkt eine pyramide können wir eben
hier so rein springen so ich zeig euch
mal ganz kurz fassen sich in der
pyramide befindet da sind eigentlich
keine so guten sachen dann halt wie
immer hier und darunter das tnt würde
ich mir auch eigentlich immer draußen
bei der pyramide die haben wir auf jeden
fall schonmal diamanten aber das sagt
der einzige die einzige die am 1
mein gott
alter bin ich bin ich jetzt irgendwie
bitte sagt mir dass er das auch seht
alter wollen mich verarschen die kissen
oh mein gott
ok
[Musik]
ich sag dazu jetzt noch nichts das ist
ich glaube diesen krank
[Musik]
herr hier nicht
die
wenn ich jeden gucke sind die und dann
hier nicht mehr erkennen klar das ist
oder das macht die sonne weil ich den
jetzt da draußen noch keine ahnung
körperkraft einen sonnenbrand
also hier erstmal eine pyramide die
immer wir müssen und kurz warten bis die
sonne da weg ist damit ihr okay ich hab
ich den weg auf die pole für amila er
ist man schon gezeigt ich finde es schön
wenn man sich eine pyramide bei seiner
ankunft und direkt hier neben haben wir
einen wüsten dorf ob gott hasst aber
sehr hell gerade machen wollen so immer
noch entschlossen keinen unterschied
auch vorbereitet labors also hier haben
wir einen wüsten dorf mit super leute
mit dem man ihr handeln kann der macht
mich jetzt auf jeden fall nicht mehr
hier haben wir halt keinen guten sachen
sind allerdings fast schon eine
komplette rüstung nichteisen brustpanzer
eisenbahn schutz und eisen stiefel und
da wir daran auf gold hatten können wir
uns da raus dann auch noch einen witz
machen einen weiteren heißen also ein
helm genau da sonst ist eigentlich
nichts halt promi dahinten hier
sonnendorf und hier haben wir noch eine
schlucht und hier sind allgemeine menge
tiere hier sehen wir jetzt sehr sehr
viele schafe für die anfangs ressourcen
sind gesorgt er ist gesorgt und zwar
betten etc und halt schweine bisschen
was zu machen
hier haben wir eine schlucht und weiß
nicht an der stoff cool findet einfach
dass überall lava und wasser raus kommt
das sieht man hier schon das sieht echt
krass aus dass sie wirklich überall lava
und was da sind alte da hinten sondern
pole und sondern zoom ist also jetzt
wirklich alles das nicht wäre wäre
franck beim und dann haben wir hinten
wieder eine schöne beta landschaft wenn
ich also sehr sehr schön ich mag das ja
immer so ihr kennt mich ich mag das ihr
kennt mich ich mag das ist eine betonung
hier diese schönen landschaften kommt
man sich echt super hinbauen finde ich
echt einfach nur klasse so was hier
wieder ein paar wiens habe ich auch
gerade zum ersten mal denkt hier unten
ins gras ok cool
na ja also das war es mit diesem motto
ich wünsch mir seit fünf minuten musik
vorstellen hier zu leihen
tut mir leid dass in letzter zeit wegen
unserer vorstellung kommen es einfach
wunderschönes wetter draußen immer wenn
ich von der schule nach hause kann man
beziehungsweise irgendwo war dann möchte
ich aber noch nicht nach draußen legen
ich muss das auch essen deswegen wenn es
euch gefallen hat gibt einfach einen
daumen hoch und schreibt in die
kommentare
und passiert die ihr eventuell auch
vorgestellt haben wollt und dann würde
ich sagen sehen wir uns beim nächsten
mal oder bei youtube.com / steffen blog
wo ihr halten bilder video sehen könnt
[Musik]